here's reaction she is the White House
press secretary Stephanie Grisham I
gotta be honest my temper it's hard now
everybody's fair game I get the crap
beat out of me every day I put myself
out there and dish it out four hours a
day I can take it
Don Jun you can take it Eric can take it
when you go on after the first lady or a
teenage kid this is a line that's
crossed but yet they justify it how come
that's allowed because if it was anybody
going after you know short of Michelle
Obama saying for the first time I'm
proud of my country bring yourself into
the arena I it's crossed lines we've
never seen Stephanie I agree and I mean
that's the tolerant left for you and
that's the left-wing media for you
children minor children of any president
and any administration should be
off-limits and the fact that after that
professor said that the room erupted in
laughter it was just it was beyond the
pale it was really unfortunate and what
was also unfortunate was that some media
seemed to really revel in it PBS did the
view did it was really unfortunate but
that's how it is with the Trump
administration right now all right let
me you work with the first lady good for
her yesterday I applaud her for calling
this out for what it is and you would
think though that the media instead of
defending it would say okay everybody
else is fair game if you're dishing it
out you're going to take some incoming
they defend it it's gotten that bad that
we now have to attack a kid and we have
to attack the first lady who attack the
first lady was hoping with opioids
reading to children yes the the answer
to that is yes the the left is so angry
they are so angry at this president
success that that's all they have left
now is to attack the first lady who's
doing nothing but try and help children
and to attack the minor child of the
first family and you know I think that
the American public sees it for what it
is that hearing was a joke it was
embarrassing and I've got to be honest
with you this morning I thought Nancy
Pelosi was going to come out and say hey
we made a mistake let's get to work and
let's do us mca they had to with what a
joke that hearing was
she didn't they're moving forward with
impeachment I think that there's gonna
be a lot of Dems that are hurt here I
think that again the American people see
what they're doing when they're when
they're going down the road of attacking
a thirteen year old child and attacking
the first lady you know they're they're
desperate right now you know you work
with the first lady a long time
Stephanie and by the way when Jimmy
Kimmel we had a big fight that I wanted
and I dare him to start it up again I
Jimmy start it just start up one more
time oh I have a lot to bring out dive
dive well I was just ready on the verge
of unloading at all but here's the thing
because she speaks five languages
English is our fifth she's traveled the
world since being a teenager highly
successful nice smart intelligent and
gets attacked for helping kids and
trying to end the opiate opioid epidemic
and then they attack her teenage son is
13 year old son and they attacked him
before he became a teenager yeah he he
is he's been you know the subject to
attacks for a long time but your point
about the first lady is that exactly
true if this was any other
administration a Democratic
administration the first lady would be
hailed and would be in all kinds of
publications and talking about be best
and all the things that are she's doing
to help children she's not but you know
what she keeps her head down she
continues to work it does not bother her
she was attacked the other day about the
coachee war in a Christmas video she's
used to this she's strong it does not
bother her at all the first family is
very strong the president is very strong
were used to this by now this was
happening to them before he even took
office this will probably be happening
after 2020 again and that's okay the
results that this family is showing for
this country that's what matters all
right Stephanie thanks for all you do
appreciate you being with us and my
offer stands a Jimmy Kimmel I dare you
start up again you will I will unload
like you've never seen
I've got it all racked up ready to go